I love sundials but not because of the  clever way they track time oh no I love  them for their mottos the centuries-old  tradition of inscribing a phrase on them  so whenever people looked at them to  check the time they would be reminded  of death  here are some famous sundials and what  they tell us man is a vanity his days  are like a shadow that passes as the  hour here you see think on death and  ready be time is the Devourer of things  time dot fly man must die  insensibly without feeling life is aging  go about your business one of ours will  be your last time flies  death comes and this one's not dark at  all although it is about the dark  without the sun I fall silent